hi i'm wandan charltiel and i'm going to
talk about hardness assumption needed
for extreme high-end physical generators
and faster randomization and this is
joint work with manuela viola
in 97 in palliative and weakness and
showed that bbp equals p assuming
certain complexity theoretic hardness
assumptions
what they did is that they constructed
high-end pseudo-random generators and by
that i mean pseudo-running generators
that are optimal up to constant factors
based on assumptions that are necessary
at least up to constant factors
and it is well known that if you have
such high-end pseudorandom generators
then dpp equals p namely there exists a
constant c such that every randomized
algorithm running in time m can be
stimulated deterministically in time m
to the c and this is wonderful we all
like this
theory recently motivated by fast
randomization that is trying to minimize
this constancy showing to throw trying
to show it to the randomization is as
fast as possible
two beautiful papers one by doron
moshkowitz oh and zuckerman and the
second one by chen and tell construct
extreme high end pseudorandom generators
these are pseudo-random generators that
are not only optimal up to constant
factors we are in fact optimizing the
constants these photovolume generators
are optimal up to one plus minus below
one factors
and these constructions of fiber random
generators are based on stronger
hardness assumptions and the assumptions
are stronger both quantitatively and
qualitatively
now
quantitatively stronger assumptions are
necessary in some sense because we're
trying to get quantitatively
pseudo-random generators but it's not at
all clear that we need qualitatively
stronger assumptions
so the question that we are addressing
in this paper is is it possible to show
but if you take the original impellation
weakness and assumption and properly
scale it quantitatively
then you can get this assumption to
imply that there exists extreme high-end
pseudo-random generators and we will be
interested in whatever exists black box
proofs achieving this score
okay so i have the assumption the new
assumptions used by these two papers
necessary
and to make a long story short we don't
know the answer to this question but
what we can do is we can rule out
certain approaches
and
our results show that the approaches of
demos and ob city cannot yield such a
black box proof giving a partial
justification of why they use stronger
assumptions
so let me tell you about the impellator
vectors on 97 theorem and this is a
setting that i call the high end the
theorem says but under a certain
hardness assumption which i'll call the
high end in polyethylene hardness
assumption
you get high-end pseudorandom generators
and let me spell out the definition of
these things so the higher the impeller
vectors and harness assumptions says
that there exists a function f on l bits
such that
f is not computable by circuits of size
2 to the omega of l
yet f can be computed by circuits of
size 2 to the o of l and i'll use t of f
to denote the time to compute f on a
single input and t all of f to be the
time that it takes
to compute f from all inputs on all two
to the l inputs and out but in the high
end if i require that t of f is 2 to the
overl this is equivalent to requiring
the t all but if i require the t of f is
2 to the overl maybe this is equivalent
to requiring the t all of f is 2 to the
order of n because because of this
constant right but later on these things
will matter
so this is the
high end imperative vectors on hardness
assumption
and the theorem says that it implies a
high-end prg
namely a pseudonym generator which
stretches a seed of length r which is
order of l into an output of length m
where m is 2 to the omega of l
and this is a pseudonym generator
meaning that it full circuits of size n
more formally but no circuits d of size
m can distinguish between the output of
a pseudo-random generator and the
uniform distribution with probability
larger than say 1 over 10 and some
constant
and
this prg is high-end
optimal up to constant factors because
the seed length r
is as small as possible at least up to
constant factor the smallest possible
seed length will be one times log n and
r is a constant times that right so this
is what i mean by a high-end prg we also
get that the pseudo-random generator uh
runs in time two to the o of l
and once again this is equivalent
because of the way the parameters are
chosen to say
that computing the pseudo-running
generator on all seeds can be done in
time two to v o l
and
when we have high-end pseudo-random
generators this implies that bpp equals
p namely that there exists a constant c
such that every randomized algorithm
that runs in time m can be simulated by
deterministic algorithm that runs in
time m to the c and this is great
let me make two comments
one is that the prg g that is
constructed in this theorem matches the
prg which is implied by the hardness
assumption up to constant factors
into
that the a high end in polyethylene
hardness assumption this harvest
assumption remains plausible even when
we scale it by constants even if we
change the
numbers here by constants and this is
why we can afford losing constant
factors
okay
so now we asked how small can this
constant c be we want faster
derandomization
and we ask what would happen if we had
extreme high-end prgs but our optimal
not only up to constant factors but only
also up to one plus minus little of one
factors so let's take a look at this
setting which i call the extreme high
end and now as i said earlier this is no
longer a theorem it's an open problem we
would like to show that
if you scale being palliative leaders on
hardness assumption correctly i'll call
this stronger assumption the extreme
high end imperial weaknesses and
hardness assumption then you obtain an
extreme high-end single random generator
and once again
let me spell these things out
so what is the extreme high end in
piazza big dozen hardness assumption
now we assume that there exists a
function f on l bits which cannot which
is not computable by circuits of size
two to the one minus little of one times
n so note that here we were allowing a
constant and here we want everything to
be optimal right no right i mean two to
the one minus little over one times n is
the largest lower one that we can think
about because every
function can be computed by a circuit of
size two to the l
we also want to optimize the constants
in the running time and now that what we
want to optimize is the time it takes to
compute f on all inputs so we want to
assume that f
can be computed computed on all inputs
in time something like 2 to the 2 l 2 to
the two plus little over one times there
so this is the correct scaling you
should trust me on that of the high-end
imperial vectors on hardness assumption
and we want this to imply an extreme
high-end prg so this is the
pseudo-renault generators generator will
be off the constants in the seed length
and the output length are optimized if
here we had a big o and big omega now we
replace them but by one plus
one and one minus below one we want
absolute generator which stretches a
seed of length one plus two over one
times lb
into m which which is almost 2 to the
edge 2 to the 1 minus or one times l
bits
and this is what an extreme high-end prg
the seed length r is one plus l of one
times log n right optimal up to one plus
below one
f factors
and
now we want but the time that it takes
to compute g on all inputs on all seeds
is roughly two to the two l two to the
two plus little over one times l and
this is best possible because for this
setting of parameters there are two two
vl seats and each one of them produces
an output length two to vl so only
outputting for all these a two to vl
outputs already takes two to the two l
times and we want when we want your time
that it takes to compute the pseudonym
generator g on all seeds to be almost
that two to the two plus zero of one
times f
okay
so
let me now compare this extreme high end
sugar random generator to the generator
that i got earlier so here g needs to
match the prg that is implied by this
hardness assumption up to one plus minus
little of one factors right we have
it needs to be much tighter than the
previous pseudonym generator and this is
because the assumption that we are
assuming the extreme high end a hardness
assumption becomes false when scaled by
constant we cannot take this 2 to the 1
minus 1 times f and scale it back by
constant because every function is
computable by a circuit of size 2
now
what what kind of deterministic
simulation do we do we get it turns out
that an extreme high-end prg implies
that c is something like 2 to the plus
little of one so we get that every
randomized algorithm that runs in time m
can be computed by determining simulated
by deterministic algorithm that runs in
time into the c where c is something
like two
and this is best possible because c
cannot be smaller there's a theorem
by carmosceno
showing that c has to be larger than two
minus little over one assuming certain
fine grain complexity
assumptions so if extreme high-end
pseudo-random generators give the best
possible constant up to this way all of
one effectors and it is an open problem
whether we can construct them from the
extreme high-end imperial victims on
hardness assumption now before
proceeding i'd like to comment
that if i asked this question what is
the smallest constant in a slightly
different way so suppose that instead of
measuring the time of a deterministic
algorithm
in terms of only the time of a
randomized algorithm but only but also
in terms of the input length of the
randomized algorithm
then it seems that the right answer is
that every randomized algorithm that can
but runs in time m of n can be
stimulated deterministically in time
something like m of n times n or m of n
times n to the one plus e log one and
this is uh follows from two beautiful
papers of uh which i already mentioned
okay
so now on the left hand side we have the
theorem in the high end we have theorem
whereas in the extreme high end we have
an open problem
so
can we use the techniques which are used
to prove
the imperative weakness on theorem to
solve the open problem in the extreme
high end so let's examine the techniques
that are used in the high end so in
polyethylene zone and later proofs use a
technique which i'll call a hardness
amplification plus the hybrid argument
so we use the hybrid argument and it
turns out
that this as well as other issues in the
proof
results in losses of constant factors
but
constant factors are not too bad in the
high end because we can afford losses of
constant factors so this is why
in the high end we have a theory
on the other hand in the extreme high
end we cannot afford
the losses of constant factors so we
cannot afford the losses include by
hardness amplification plus the hybrid
argument we cannot afford these
techniques and this is why we have
an open problem rather than a theory
nevertheless as i said in the beginning
these two beautiful papers were one by
erdogan moscow it's owen zuckerman and
the second one by chairman tell by past
this barrier and be sure how to
construct extreme high-end pseudo-random
generators i'll albeit assuming
qualitatively stronger assumptions but i
will now reveal
okay
so let's start with the the first
paper the paper of demons and then was
say the following
we'll take a look at this open problem
we can make it
a theorem
if we strengthen the hardness assumption
so if
if instead of assuming that f is hard
for standard circuits we assume that f
is not computable by circuits of size
two to one minus minus zero one times
their circuits but are stronger but are
also equipped with non-determinism and
randomness and this is a stronger
assumption but doesn't seem to be
necessary in bisetti
right so uh this is the demos paper and
i'll take let's take a look at the chain
and tell paper
so challenge say we take a look at this
open problem and we can
make it a theorem
if we throw in an additional assumption
and we now also assume in addition to
the extreme high end in political
victims on hardness assumption we also
assume that way functions exist now once
again i'm not saying but one way
functions are impossible of course they
are possible i'm only saying but they
don't seem to be necessary in this
setting
okay so let's go back to the outline and
see where we are
so i've told you what is the open
problem i'm interested in
namely
is it possible to show
that
that the extreme high end in political
victims on hardness assumption implies
extreme high-end pseudorandom generator
this was the open problem that i had on
the previous slide
and since i'll be interested
in showing negative results improving
limitations i'll be interested in black
box proofs and the way i want to ask
this question
is is there a black box proof showing
this
implication and for this i need to tell
you what black box proofs are
so let's take a look at black box proof
so here i have the open problem that i'm
studying i'm asking whether you can take
a function f and convert it into
pseudorandom generator
g let me define what black box proofs
are
and i start by saying that all known
pseudorandom generator constructions
have black box proof in the following
a blackboard proof
consists of two things the first thing
is a construction map
this is a map e
which
takes the function f and convert it into
a function g i call g
or call it gf so it takes a function f
and it converts it into function g it
can receive any function s not
necessarily a heart function so where
does the correctness come comes in
the correctness comes in
by the fact that we require that there
exists the reduction namely an oracle
circuit r such that for every function f
and for every potential adversary d not
necessarily a small circuit
if d
breaks the pseudo randomness of gf
namely if d distinguishes the output of
gf from uniform
then when r receives oracle access to d
then it needs to compute f using few
queries to the oracle d
okay
together these two things show that if f
is hard then g is pseudorandom why is
that because if g is not pseudorandom if
there's a small circuit distinguishing
the output of gf from uniform but is
breaking gf
then
since d is a small circuit and r makes
few oracle queries today then r with
oracle access to d is also a small
circuit
and so since r with oracle access to d
computes f and f is not hot so we've
just shown that
if there exists a circuit d as well
circuit d which breaks the
pseudo-randomness of gf then f is not
hard establishing the open problem okay
with the right parameters
so now there's an asterisk here because
the actual definition of what is a
reduction is slightly more complicated
in this setting of hard functions to
pseudorandom generated this is
completely standard so let me just
write it here in small letters the
reduction r in this setting
is allowed to be non-uniform what do i
mean by non-uniform reduction
it means that when receives oracle
access to d it is also allowed to ask
for a shortage y string
which depends on both the function f and
the adversary d and it turns out that
this this is the right notion when you
understand when you want to study
a black box proofs from hard functions
to pseudorandom generators and you
should trust me on that i'm not going to
go into this
in this talk
so now i can state the question that i
wanted to ask formally the question is
does there exist an extreme black box
truth namely a black box proof showing
that you can start from the extreme high
end in paratroopness on hardness
assumption and obtain
extreme high-end prgs and as i said in
the beginning of the talk we don't know
how to answer this problem this is a
great question
uh but even though we don't know how to
answer it whether there exists such a
black box proof of it does not exist
such a black box too we can rule out
certain approaches for coming up with
such black box proofs
okay so finally after this long
introduction i get to tell you about our
results
which are limitations on some specific
approaches for obtaining extreme black
box proof
our first result is that in every black
box proof even one that is not extreme
even the ones that we already know
the construction map e which is mapping
the function f into the candidate
pseudo-random generator g-sub-f
must have certain special properties
which i will explain precisely in the
next slide
and we think that these special
properties explain why it is hard to
come up with new black box group it's
difficult to come up with constructions
with these special properties
but now that we know how
they're supposed to look maybe this will
help us to find out to find new
constructions uh because we know that
the ones that we already have by nissan
and weakness on and by humans and myself
cannot succeed in the extreme high end
so if you want to we want constructions
that will work in the extreme high end i
we need to come up with new
construction maps
uh let me also point out that these
special properties are used to prove the
next result
our second result
is that
if we if you use the approach of demos
of the paper that i've told you about
earlier and i'll call this approach a
pseudo-entropy generator plus extractor
approach then this approach cannot yield
an extreme black box proof
and this explains why demos needed to
use additional assumptions because it's
impossible to have a black box proof
without using these these additional
assumptions
and i'll explain this more precisely
later on
in our third result we take a look at
the paper of shen and pal
they use an approach which i'll call the
prg composition approach and here the
result is less conclusive what we show
is that the pseudo-random generator
composition approach cannot yield an
extreme black box proof if you use
hardness amplification and the hybrid
argument
now the known constructions in the
literature use hardness simplification
in the hybrid argument and starting from
assumptions writing political victims
and hardness assumption so we think that
this explains why the paper of shannon
tell
has to use additional assumptions has to
use one-way functions
but
let me just say that right as i as i
just said it doesn't rule out such a prg
composition approach an intel can be
carried out without the harness
amplification plus the hybrid argument
so this is
for maybe this is a place where we can
look for a a new kind of black box proof
so i'll now elaborate about the three
results i told you about i'll start with
the first one
and i want to tell you what are these
special properties that reconstruction
map e needs to have
and
in order to tell you about these
properties
uh let's view a function f on l bits as
its truth table namely an n equals 2 to
the l long b string
and this allows us to view the
construction map e
as a map that takes two arguments it
takes the hard function f
which is now an n bit long string
and a seed x
of length r and it outputs g s of x
whatever candidate observant generator g
would have done on the seat x
and the reason i want this notation is
because once i define e this way
a classical theorem by trevison from 99
shows that black box pseudo-random
generators are extractors namely but
every search function e which is a black
box
which is a which is a construction map
for black box proof
is an extractor meaning that for every
high entropy source
f over m bit strings
if we apply the extractor on an extended
independent random seed the output is
close to unif
okay so what is the special properties
that a construction map needs to have
our result says that every construction
map e has a following special property
there is a high entropy source f
on which quite a few outputs of e
are fixed
and if we examine these two statements
you can see that these two results are
at a tension
because in an extractor it can't be that
many outputs of e on f are fixed because
this would contradict the fact that the
output needs to be close to uniform
so the difference is between
quite a few and many on the one hand
we show that quite a few outputs of e
are fixed whereas it can't be that many
outputs are fixed so these so so the
fact that
a function e is a construction map for a
black box the pseudo-random generator
is in tension with the fact that it has
to be an extractor
another way of thinking about it is the
following result that we have
a random function e
is on the one hand with high probability
and extractor this is a standard
calculation but a random function e with
these parameters
is with high probability and x factor
nevertheless what we can show is that
with high probability it does not
satisfy this special property so it's
not going to be part of the black box
proof
and a compact way of saying this is that
e must be diffic different than a
typical extractor a construction map e
for a black box proof must be different
from a typical extractor and we find it
quite surprising is we tend to think of
black box pseudonym generators in this
extent of extractors is similar whereas
it turns out that they need to be quite
different right in order for a mapping e
to be a a construction map for a black
box proof
it it has to be on the one hand it needs
to be an extractor this is what revision
says but in the one on the other hand it
needs to be careful not to do too well
right because there's a tension
between what it has to do and the fact
that it is an extractor
let me say one sentence about the
intuition for the proof and the
intuition for the proof is the following
suppose that he does not have this
special property
right suppose that is in fact very
different from having this special
property suppose that
when you
apply it on a
a function f that is chosen from the
uniform distribution all the outputs of
a e on such an f have high entropy none
of them are fixed or even close to being
fixed
if this was the case then i claim that
the reduction r will not be able to find
such outputs of e because we have our
entropy how can the reduction find them
and since it can't find group it will
not be able to make use of its oracle
and will therefore fail therefore since
we know that the reduction does not fail
uh
in
using its oracle to compute f
it must be the case
that at least
some outputs quite a few have
low entropy
and we can fix these outputs without
losing too much entropy reducing
reducing the distribution from the
uniform distribution to some high
entropy source on which quite a few of
the outputs are fixed so this is the
intuition for the proof uh there are
technicalities in making this
information into a formal proof but i'm
not going to go into this
uh let me now elaborate on the second
result that the approach of demos can't
yield an extreme blackboard group
so let's recall the theorem of demos
show how to construct extreme
extreme high-end pseudorandom generators
from a qualitatively stronger version of
the extreme high end in periods of
victories on harness assumption
in which
we assume that the function is hard not
only against standard circuits but also
again circuits that are equipped with
non-determinism and randomness so that's
the result i told you about earlier
how is this result proven
must use an approach which i'll call the
pseudoentropy generator plus extractor
approach which was already used in some
previous papers
and a
disappearance can be stated as follows
you use the heart function f
to construct a pseudoentropy generator
with certain parameters but i'll explain
later but first let me explain what a
pseudoentropy generator is
epsilon entropy generator is a weak form
of obstruction
guarantees that the output has large
computational entropy rather than
guaranteeing that the output is
pseudorandom that is but it is
indistinguishable from from random
instead of being distinguished
it only guarantees that
it has computational entropy which means
that it is indistinguishable from having
high entropy or actually mean and joke
and
the approach continues by constructing
the final prg in the following form you
apply the pseudo-entropy generator on a
random speed x now the output has
computational entropy
and so you extract this computation
entropy using an extractor with an
additional c so a final construction
that you get is a pseudonym generator
which takes two seeds x and y apply the
pseudoentropy generator of the first
feed and then applies an extractor with
the second c to extract the
computational entropy and obtain the
pseudo-random distribution
now the seed length of this final
generator is of course the sum of the
seed lengths of the true object the
length of x plus the length of y
now we know how long
a seeds of extractors need to be so we
know but the second seed why the seed of
the extractor has to be long it has to
be of length almost l
and since we are shooting to construct a
pseudo running generator which is an
extreme high-end pseudorandom generator
in which the speed length is also almost
n one plus l over one times n then the
second uh
then the length of x must be very very
short right we've already used all our
budget on y and we must have but the
length of x would be little of n
right so this is the approach of demos
now our result is that in every
extreme
a black box proof in every black box
proof from extreme high end in palestine
harnesses something to
entropy generators
it it must be the case
that the length of the seed the length
of x is large is almost l and so it
cannot be little over
now this means that it is impossible to
have an extreme black box proof using
the pseudoentropy generator plus
extractor approach so this is the result
i told you about you can't use the
approach of demos to start from the
extreme end imperial victims and harness
assumption
and
since
pseudoentropy generators are closely
connected to pseudorandom generators for
quantified randomization this also
implies limitations on fluorine
generators from for quantified
randomization and i'm not going to say
if you know what quantified the
randomization is then that's great and
if not i'm not i'm not going to go into
this more precisely
let me say a few words about the proof
idea
uh it turns out that we have four
mentioned special properties of prgs
that very is a high entropy source on
which the
output of which a quite a few outputs of
the
e are fixed
in fact applies also to pages right so
so
it also holds for pages
and just like we've seen
that in the case of prgs this is there's
a tension between being able a black box
prg and the index information theoretic
analog and extractor
in this setting there is a tension
between being a pg episode entropy
generator and its information theoretic
analog which is a condenser an extractor
that only outputs
a high entropy output
and when the length of the seed x of the
pg is very short this tension becomes so
strong that it is a contradiction and
it's impossible to have black box
proofs
but have a a small length a seed and
this is why it follows that the seed
length of the pg must be large right
that's the high level of the proof
let me now tell you about the third
result regarding the approach of chen
and tell and let's first recall the
theorem of genome 10 a challenge will
show that extreme high-end prgs follow
if you assume the extreme high-end
imperial victims and hardness assumption
but you also need to assume that one-way
functions exist
and they use an approach which i'll call
the composition approach namely the
generator g
is constructed in two step
you first apply a generator g1 on the
seed x and then you apply a second
generated g2 on g1 of x
where and i'm now going to tell you what
are the properties of these two
generators
the first generator g1 starts from the
seed length that we want one plus little
over one times l
but it doesn't go all the way to an
output like two to the one minus low of
one times l that we want it stops in the
middle it only outputs m one bits where
m m one is two to the omega of l
but when it outputs these m1 bits these
m1 bits full circuits of much larger
sample the size that we do
so this prg one full circuits of the
sides that we do want to pull but it
doesn't output the amount of beats that
we want
and it turns out and this is a
an observation of challenger but such
pseudonym generators
can be constructed from the extreme high
end in projectile vectors and harness
assumption by using the
the methods that we know how to use
hardest amplification and the hybrid
argument by extending the previous
pseudorandom generators
then the second generated d2 does the
rest of the job it's right it receives
the feed of length m1 right i mean the
the the the length of the output that we
had for the first pseudorandom generator
and it stretches it
to the to the side to the length that we
wanted two to the minus little over one
times l which in terms of m1 is
polynomial in m1
so v2 is a pseudonym generator with
polynomial stretch from m1 bits to m1 to
some constant
uh air beats
and the way uh can intel obtain this
pseudonym generator is that they
they take this
generator as a cryptographic to the
random generator that follows from one
way function
but you could ask right why do they take
that why do they use a cryptographic
pseudorandom generator why do they why
do they need to assume one-way functions
this isn't pseudonymous generator with
mild stretch
right with only polynomial stretch and
we've already seen that you can
construct the wrong generators with
almost exponential stretch
assuming
the imperative we don't start assumption
so where do one-way functions come in
the reason why the assumption comes in
one way functions come in is that in
order to perform the composition you
also need an additional property and
what you need is that we generated g2
should run in time which is almost
linear in its output rate so this is its
output length and it needs to run it
down which is almost linear in that
and the reason that you need this is
because when you argue that composition
works
then you consider g2 as a as a potential
distinguisher from the point of view of
g1 so g2 cannot have size which is
larger than 2 to the l it must have
smaller size so the g1 will fool it but
in any case g2 needs to run in time
which is almost linear in its output
length and the known techniques that we
use the hardness amplification plus
hybrid argument do not give photorandom
generators with these parameters they
you can obtain absolute around generated
g2 with polynomial strength but it
doesn't end up running in almost linear
time in its output
so the quest an actual question that you
should ask is is there a black box proof
starting from the assumptions but
between one
of the extreme high end in pareto
vectors on hardness assumption and
constructing a pseudonym generator like
g2 absolute random generator with
polynomial stretch that runs in time it
is almost linear in its output
and
our result is that it is impossible for
black box proofs to obtain
such pseudo-random generators
if they use hardness amplification plus
the hybrid argument so this is a weaker
result than the one i had on the
previous slide we don't know how to rule
out any black box proof of this flow of
this form but we do know but if you use
hardness amplification plus the hybrid
argument then you can't obtain g2 from
the assumption from which we want to
start
and let me tell you a couple of things
about this result
so this result is essentially showing
limitation on black box proofs for
hardness amplification in the extreme
high end we are in the extreme high end
and we want to show that that there's a
cost to harness amplification that
prevents you from obtaining the
pseudorandom generator that's running
almost linear time
and we already have limitations on black
box proof of hardness amplification in
earlier works the best previous result
is in a paper by a
a greenberg viola and myself
but that paper and also the the previous
papers uses techniques that do not work
in the extreme high end it they only
work in the high end and the point is
that now you want to extend
these results to the extreme high end
and we need to come up with this with a
completely different proof technique and
the proof technique
builds on earlier works
one by a
apple
a young and myself and the second one
by once we er varma and myself and
what these
what this really amounts to is what you
want to prove a lower bound on the
number of queries required by local
least decodable codes and
along the way we don't we're not
we don't only prove a new lower bounds
for having simplification but we also
proved improved lower bounds on the
number of queries required by localistic
global goals
in a certain regime of parameters
so
finally let me conclude and give you
some open problems so this is the
summary of the talk the main question
the answer and the interpretation
and
let me make a comment and that is that
in this talking in this paper i focused
on pseudorandom generators
but there are other approaches
to prove that hard functions imply bpp
equals p without pseudo-random
generators
and the limitations that i've shown
in this talk do not apply for these
approaches and in particular we do not
apply for a very recent paper of a
children tails so if you're only
interested in their randomization not
extruding generators
this may be another avenue in which you
can bypass
our limitations uh
so let me now mention some open problems
so of course the most important open
problem is this question is there a
black box proof showing that if you take
a quantity
scaled in parenthood's assumption mainly
the extreme high-end
imperative zone assumption then
you can obtain extreme high-end
pseudorandom generators and as i said
we do not know how to solve this problem
a more
easier and more technical open problems
are the following problems
one
the quantitative bounds that we get for
blackboard proofs for honest
amplification at the extreme high end
the ones which i just told you about in
the previous slide are not tight
and this is disappointing because the in
the high end we do have such tight bound
from the work of the with the greenberg
and
viola so it would be interesting to er
extend the bounds that we have in the
extreme high end to be tight
a second a problem which is probably
much more difficult
is
is the following
is the cost of hardness amplification
plus hybrid argument necessary for black
box proofs for prg's
right uh
we don't know how right i mean in the
sense that
other black box proofs for prgs
which do better than hard simplification
and the hybrid argument
and in order to attack this problem we
need to develop techniques to prove even
very weak bounds on general black box
proof for prgs because as you can see in
this paper we were not able to handle
general black box proofs for prgs we
could only handle black box proofs for
prg's which have certain properties like
if they had a a if there were
a pg plus extractor approach or if they
were there a prg composition approach
and at this point we don't know how to
prove even very weak bounds against
general blackboard for prg's
so that's it